les terrasses et les lieux de vie ont
rouvert il ya maintenant deux semaines
je pense moment la vidéo ça je suis
ravie mois ce qui manquait le plus c'est
d'aller au musée tout le temps j étais
on le voyait à droite au musée d'orsay à
gauche au musée du louvre qui y croit un
peu
écoutez vous savez j'ai une culture
générale proche du néant mais j'aime
bien les musées soyons fiers on a le
look c'est le plus beau musée du monde
si je dis pas de bêtise est alors au
piège d'une bêtise ya quoi vive la
france vive la république
d'ailleurs sachez que vous pouvez
visiter gratuitement le louvre
virtuellement sur leur site et c'est pas
une op je le dis parce que voilà je suis
un peu ambassadeurs de la culture sur
youtube en france ouais aujourd'hui on
va parler musée sachez qu'il existe des
musées pour à peu près tout ce qui
existe à peu près et compris certains
qui sont très concept on va checker
ensemble les musées les plus incongrues
qui existent aussi sachez qu'on a sorti
des nouveautés sur lyokô shop ce
splendide ou dit ce merveilleux tee
shirt ce somptueux tapis peuvent être un
fou on rentre tout de suite dans le
coeur du sujet saviez vous qu'il existe
un musée des cheveux le rêve de tous les
call vicieux comme moi et devinez où est
ce qu'ils se situent sur cette carte du
monde en turquie évidemment les turcs
c'est quoi votre délire avec les cheveux
la doua bi je suis à deux doigts
t'appeler pourrons en discuter
[Musique]
va t il parler français attendez je
viens de comprendre le concept du musée
tu y vas tu dis oui bonjour j'ai des
cheveux on te répond oui bonjour je vous
en prendre un petit peu et je vais leglu
et à un post it sur le mur et ça donne
le musée du cheveu c'est fou
[Musique]
toute la côte basque aux mosquées à
l'huile est génial j'ai envie qu'ils me
racontent des histoires lui avant de me
tuer j'adore les musiques sachez-le
terre ça me fait penser il ya un groupe
turc lac à percer avec un souk excellent
qui s'appelle supl guessing comme dame
pierre accents les turcs se désabonnent
c'est pas grave j'arrive au barrage de
près une petite belge toi viens par ici
que j'étais la coupe
il est passionné regardez la passion sur
ce visage c'est incroyable bon le bilan
c'est quoi c'est qu'il faut que j'aille
absolument dans ce musée rapidement
avant que les incidents tant redouté sur
yan tu me manqueras aubade be done by et
la turquie qui m'appelle au le musée de
la ventriloquie ça alors comment ça rend
[Musique]
c'est dur avec ses antennes est appelé
les war m appelait les warren tourner un
conte jury glab a fait un truc imagine
un petit fait une blague
le soir tu y vas et il est assis parmi
les marionnettes il bouge pas comme leur
en est il est assis parmi les
reconnaître comme ça exactement comme ça
excusez moi je dis vous faire peur en
criant aux buts inscrits au bilan
exactement comme ça il ya tout et
marionnettes et y'a un mec au milieu que
ça a pu tin oo il peut bouger son vie
mais attendez je suis à deux doigts de
devenir fan de ventriloque là c'est
grâce et des vraies oeuvres d'art en
fait il peut se décoller les oreilles
comme certains humains j'ai jamais su le
faire est ce que ça nous fait tous un
peu frissonner bad et le délire poupée
ce qui est bizarre c'est que ça même pas
lié au film d'horreur moi j'ai jamais vu
de ce qui est tout et je suis pas
spécialement sensible aux poupées et
diabolique méchante je m'en fous un peu
même annabelle jeu ça m'a pas plus que
ça c'est vraiment l'objet en lui-même
terrifie j'arrive pas à re pourquoi à la
fête foraine là quant à me les 85 euros
là au ballon tu gagnes lui toute ta vie
il est là sur une chaise en face de ton
lit
c'est tout y'a pas de chez eux en vrai
c'est vraiment des bêtes d'objets c'est
de l'art tout c'est peut-être là c'est
vraiment de la relégation la guerre
est-ce que moi il ya deuxième vidéo et
de données à cette photo c'est un film
d'horreur
toi tu es très classe cool vasif joue
dans des pubs de parfum mais lâche cette
marionnette bons messieurs dames
bienvenue au musée des parasites à tokyo
ouais mais ce qui l'est c'est la cades
les chiba c'est très méprisante quand je
résume impayés en quatre mots parasites
étant la chose la plus répugnante qui
existe sur cette planète c'est vraiment
un petit organisme qui viennent entre
organismes et qui se nourrit de tout
organisme pour grandir c'est horrible
c'est peut-être parce à la définition on
attendait puisque là je vais me prendre
le lobby du youtube scientifiques sur le
dos faut que je fasse très attention
définition parasites que tout le monde
garde son calme attendait attendait la
police est ce qui vit aux dépens d'un
autre sans le détruire à la police
souvent j'ai eu beau olalalala ans mais
quelle horreur et le nom de maladie qui
a dans cet endroit imagine voilà où en
est le co vide il ya un touriste il a
fait tomber une fiole frérot terminée
c'est vraiment dégueulasse j'arrive pas
à croire que c'est des vrais parasites
et que c'est pas genre des
représentations à ça c'est ça c'est
terrible
allez petit verre coquille avec les
pattes là comme ce que seb prenait
calmement après il était très serein
c'est clairement je pense qu'il en a 2 3
chez lui en animaux de compagnie c'est
obligé c'est vraiment assez dégueulasse
aux crises acier qu'est ce qu'il fait là
haut c'est qu'on est à tokyo donc de
temps en temps c'est pas un parasite
c'est un pokémon quoi dans le truck dr
pod
c'est très loin ses douze minutes mais
on va la regarder et on prend du plaisir
j'avais vu une vidéo à l'époque je ne
vous montrerai pas évidemment qui était
horrible c'est un mec qui se faisait
retirer un parasite qui était dense aux
fins fonds de son nez bah là où le test
pcr atterri et bien à lui à cet endroit
là y'avait pas du mucus il y avait un
truc qui vivaient là il se fait retirer
le truc il est comme ça ils sortent du
pif c'est horrible mais les gars à
parasites reconnu le parasite du coup le
ver solitaire que je me sois quand
j'étais jeune ma mère ne m'avait parlé
de ça ça m'avait traumatisé m'avait dit
oui voilà en fait ils rentrent en toi et
il y mange la nourriture que tu en gère
à ta place tu as une bonne partie est du
coup il grandit et il peut faire jusqu'à
et pour l'évacuer il faut prendre un
médicament et tu le chi voilà c'est bon
je vais le vannetais a c'est trop et
c'est dégueulasse
allez ça dégage remettez mois les
marionnettes lorraine pourquoi tu vas me
cette merde à
tu me connais bien le musée des
toilettes
il a été inventé pour moi un musée
d'être honnête au coeur de new delhi le
directeur monsieur rana s'est pris
d'intérêt pour le sujet sliders ce gas
and il peut d'ailleurs expliquer en
détail toute l'évolution des toilettes
de 2500 ans avant jésus-christ jusqu'à
nos jours il est passionné du cul
amusant de voir les trésors
d'ingéniosité déployés par les hommes
pour satisfaire ce besoin naturel mais
grave grave show en réellement je trouve
ça intéressant et ça sans feinte à alep
et radio soit si le vc en fauteuil les
gens venaient soulever le coussin
bon on n'est pas sur un truc de ouf quoi
excusez moi mais on n'est pas sur un
truc ingénieux de fulda juste trouver
une chaise damien sont en dessous bon
les enfants bienvenus au musée du cul
regardez un peu toutes ces belles
toilettes
du coup ils vendent plein de toiles est
différente pour toutes les bourses
hockey en toile et turcs
marantis j'ai été traumatisé turquie
encore mais qu'est ce qui se passe dans
cette vidéo et on va pouvoir faire le
tri habituel avec la turquie la turquie
et je veux les toilettes et les petites
pâtisseries mignonne je suis très
content d'être venu ici on prend
conscience ici que faire ses besoins
dehors et nuisible pour l'environnement
blague à part la savez c'est un pays
culturellement qui est très différent du
nôtre la bayanne 1,3 milliard
d'habitants où il ya beaucoup de gens
que jamais été sensibilisés au fait de
faire ses besoins dans un lieu fait pour
ça ak des toilettes et le souci c'est
que du coup ça engendre des vrais
problèmes d'hygiène et donc de maladies
etc
donc en fait ce musée il a un réel
intérêt en inde c'est de sensibiliser
les gens aux toilettes et aussi de
d'équiper ces zones très pauvre en toile
est en fait finalement
mais effectivement nous entends français
quand on voit ça boit ça nous fait rire
évidemment musée du cul le musée des
spermes au fil c'est un genre de petit
écureuil calme nous annoncer les musées
ou c'est des trucs empaillés hall
un peu de respect et opérer les justes
dans le jardin le musée ce n'est pas
obligé la taxidermie c'est tout un art
etc
pas de problème ça me glace le sang
voilà c'est bon j'ai très honnête je
suis pas bien des joies un truc en
paille et même les têtes là les têtes
sur les murs c'est horrible j'ai jamais
compris de prochain musée se trouve aux
états unis les poteaux la musculature
faut que j'arrête c'est résumé il s'agit
du concurrent direct du musée des
cheveux de nos amis les turcs
et oui le frérot là il a du souci à se
faire parce qu'au musée des cheveux de
leïla ce n'est pas des chevaux qui
pendent au mur ce sont des oeuvres d'art
constitué de cheveux oh c'est encore un
maire des colliers en cheveux non là je
crois que c'est plus mal ça en fait que
le musée en turquie c'est comme si un
gars y tuer des humains il faisait
d'être au beau sac en cuir d'humains
magnifique avec ses encore plus creepy
s'est donné du mal et toucher ans elle
est la propriétaire du musée elle à un
cheveu de joe et nick un cheveu
d'abraham lincoln quoi comment tu peux
savoir que s'achevait d'abraham lincoln
les gars dans ma famille on a des
cheveux de marilyn monroe donc je les
vends là on exclusivité je me suis tué
les cheveux pour faire cette black le
prochain musée messieurs dames se trouve
en gros à 6 g rien alors les poètes
moody se trouvant parmi les squido cela
ils vont vraiment être touché en plein
coeur c'est le musée de la rupture
sortez les mouchoirs on va être dans ma
ce musée c'est très simple c'est des
couples qui se sont séparés et l'un des
deux décident de venir exposer un objet
qui lui rappelle son couple pour x
raisons et donc des à chaque objet il ya
une petite note un petit journal qui
raconte l'histoire du couple est
pourquoi ils sont séparés
c'est vachement touchant je trouve
l'amour c'est beau je veux dire c'est
mieux que l'aide ou quoi
[Musique]
mais ça les gars sa monture qu'ils aient
déjà je trouve ce musée est excellent je
trouve vraiment que c'est une bonne idée
ça dédramatise beaucoup la rupture
toutes les histoires sont vachement
différente chez pas c'est beau quoi je
trouve ça vraiment cool je jure c'est
mieux que les castors empaillés l'espère
mot filoche pas quoi je respecte pas et
enfin messieurs dames le plus petit
musée au monde c'est un mec qui voulait
ouvrir un musée c'est très touchant et
sauf qu'il avait rien et du coup il a
fait juste eu une pièce dans laquelle il
a il met des trucs qui trouve qui réussi
à choper à droite à gauche il a fait un
musée avec ça c'est déjà génial the
words words d'esprit cette chasse
il ya vraiment de tout voyageur des
vieux journaux des vieilles photos voilà
je voulais vous montrer ce gala trouver
une autre touche on a voulu faire un
musée il l'a fait messieurs dames c'est
la fin de cette vidéo j'ai vu y'a pas
longtemps qu'elle marque et squeeze sur
mon casque
il m'a fallu du temps je trouve ça
vachement touchant de voir tous ces gens
ouvrir passionnés en fait d ouvrir un
lieu dans lequel il expose des trucs
qu'il est touché à travers lesquels il
souhaite toucher aussi d'autres
personnes je sois vraiment beau j'espère
que ça vous a plu que vous avez été
intrigué par le game des musées on va
bientôt pouvoir voyager chercher quand
vous êtes dans un pays très souvent ya
des tout petits musées qui sont
vachement intéressant donc voila tu
conseille à mes squido c'est finalement
voilà allez à bientôt passer une
agréable journée soirée du matinée peu
importe partait à l'est
[Musique]